Some of us like to spend our weekend with
a book in hand, while others prefer a night
out being the centre of attention. But from
a scientific perspective, is there an advantage
to being an introvert or an extrovert? Which
is better?
The idea of two polar personalities was first
described by Swiss German psychologist Carl
Jung, who coined the terms introversion and
extraversion. Jung’s theory was further
elaborated upon by Hans Eysenck, a German
psychologist who defined introverts and extroverts
by their baseline arousal. Extroverts, with
their lower level of arousal, would need to
do more exciting things that would physically
and mentally exhaust an introvert, in order
to reach satisfaction. So while an introvert
might be content with a leisurely bicycle
ride through a quiet park, an extrovert might
need to hit the dirt roads in order to feel
mentally satisfied.
Brain scans show a thicker prefrontal cortex
in introverts compared to extroverts, which
is associated with deeper thought and planning,
suggesting that extroverts may be more impulsive
than introverts, who prefer to ‘mull things
over’ instead of directly springing into
action. But because of this tendency to ruminate
in introverts, they’re also more susceptible
to developing anxiety and depression.
Extroverts also respond more strongly to rewards,
with brain scans showing a significantly more
activated dopamine reward system than introverts,
when completing and winning a computerized
gambling task. And given that we’re social
animals, dopamine is also released when interacting
with other humans. This was especially important
as hunter-gatherers who relied upon others
for both food and protection from predators.
However, human connection has a greater impact
on extroverts than introverts. In fact, it
has been shown that the brains of extroverts
respond more strongly when shown photos of
humans faces compared to neutral photos of
nature. For introverts, the brain response
is similar between the two.
Now, that’s not to say that introverts don’t
feel any excitement from winning or that they
strongly dislike being around people. But
they simply don’t feel as excited and don’t
require as much social interaction in order
to feel good.
In terms of genetics, there may be an evolutionary
advantage to each trait. For instance, introverts
might have stuck to the sidelines to avoid
predators, while extroverts would roam and
explore giving them an advantage when food
is scarce. A study involving 130 participants
discovered that those who were more inclined
to be adventurous had two copies of one particular
allele (Met/Met), reinforcing the idea that
these personality traits are partially linked
to genetics.
In many ways our society has an extroversion
bias, where qualities like ‘putting yourself
out there’ are highly valued. Our institutions
are also often designed with the extroverts
in mind, where ‘group work’ is a popular
practice in most schools and workplaces, with
the idea that creativity comes from a sociable
place. However, as social animals we instinctively
mimic others opinions without realizing it,
suggesting that your brainstorming sessions
with others may not always be productive.
When we disagree with a group, neuroscientists
have shown high activation in the amygdala
- a part of the brain associated with the
sting of rejection.
When we think of introverts, shyness and the
preference to be alone often come to mind,
but in reality, introverts may simply prefer
close conversations with one or a few people,
instead of dozens. Furthermore, introverts
may even be better public speakers, as they
are known to think through ideas thoroughly
compared to extroverts, who may choose to
make rash decisions instead.
But, perhaps you are an ambivert, right in
the middle of the introvert/extrovert Venn
diagram, combining the best of both worlds!
A recent study involving 340 call centre representatives
had their sales record tracked for a period
of three months. Those who were neither strong
extroverts or introverts generated the most
revenue, averaging $208 per hour, compared
to the study average of $138 per hour.
So, what do you see yourself as? And do you
think one is better than the other?
Let us know in the comments below!
Special thanks to audible for supporting this
episode to give you a free 30 day trial at
audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend
the book “Introvert Power: Why Your Inner
Life Is Your Hidden Strength” which analyzes
strategies for introverts to excel, living
in an extroverted world! You can get a free
30 day trial at audible.com/asap and choose
from a massive selection! We love them as
they are great when you’re on the go.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!